welcome back to Long Prime daily
everybody for this story we're going to
go to the West Coast we're a podcaster
and her husband were killed in Redmond
Washington apparently by an obsessed fan
it happened early Friday morning police
say a stalker broke into zory sodegi's
home through her mother's window the
mother managed to get away but the
gunman Ramen kodakor ramazai killed
sodegi and his Hut and her husband Malad
nasseri he then turned the gun on
himself police say the suspect started
listening to sedeggy on the platform
Clubhouse where she streamed a show and
Farsi about getting a job in the tech
industry she and the suspect apparently
became friends but his actions became
increasingly concerning so she
eventually got a no contact order in
fact according to paperwork he had
harassed her by phone for months
sometimes calling 100 times a day he
also harassed her husband and sent gifts
to her home even showing up wants to
deliver them in person police granted
the protection order but because the
suspect is a long-haul trucker they
weren't able to find him to serve the
paperwork before the murders
I would just remind uh the public that
are restraining order is simply a piece
of paper that allows officers to take
enforcement action should a suspect
violate the court order but a piece of
paper does not protect a person when
someone is intent on causing them harm
the the message to them is just in this
case this victim did to work closely
with investigators to allow us to seek
that restraining order so we can take
enforcement action should a suspect
violate it but I do not want to create a
false sense of security just because a
restraining order or a protective order
is obtained that that is uh you know
some type of Shield that it is important
for them to report each and every
violation of that court order so that we
can actually uh so that the prosecutor
can then actually bring that person
forward for justice based upon violating
that court order in this case the victim
did everything that they possibly could
unfortunately this person you know broke
into their home and and killed her and
it is a tragic event it's such a sad
story Terry he reignites the
conversation what's the process for
obtaining a protective order well you
know in this instance Washington state
has different types of protective orders
they have domestic violence they have
harassment this was a stalking
protective order and what the petitioner
does is they file this petition and they
allege that the respondent was stalking
them and they can if the court allows it
get a temporary restraining order and
then there's a hearing to determine
whether or not there should be a
permanent restraining order and once you
get it one of the things you have to do
is to make sure that you report any type
of infraction on that protective order
just as you heard the officer there
State because it's really important that
they follow up and also once you get it
in the state of Washington it is
enforceable in any other state in the
country so that's one good thing you
don't have to continue filing these
protective orders if you decide to move
yeah Brian so there's an order of
protection put in place here how did
things escalate with two people dead
far too quickly and I kind of want to
focus on what the officer said during
that interview I get what he's saying
it's a piece of paper it's much like a a
stop sign people can choose to abide by
it or not but I do believe there could
have been greater help by the police to
ensure their safety a hundred phone
calls delivering packages I mean
oftentimes I'm on the other side I'm the
defense attorney saying hey this order
protection is not necessary the person
wants to go and see their child because
it's between two spouses or what it may
be but this seemed pretty clear-cut
there probably should have been a
protective order along with a protective
detail by police officers and ensuring
that this person wasn't coming over and
over again it seems like they fell short
of protecting this woman in they could
have done more even though she did
everything she could yeah I think he he
said it best it's everyone's worst
nightmare in these kinds of stalking
situations while there is another brutal
killing that's making headlines this
time in Minnesota deputies say a father
killed an elderly sex offender using a
shovel and a moose antler deputies say
Levi Axtell showed up at the Sheriff's
Office drunk and covered in blood
admitting to the murder he says he used
the shovel to hit Lauren Scully a known
sex offender 15 to 20 times he said he
then finished him off with a large moose
Handler Axtell claims Scully stalked his
two-year-old daughter back in 2018 he
says that Scully would park his van and
watch the child go on walks near her
daycare an order of protection was
granted for a few weeks and none
ultimately dismissed for now Axtell is
being held without bond as he awaits an
April court date
[Music]
we've shared stories of Prison Breaks
high-speed Chase's fugitives on the run
but our next suspect out of Utah
apparently wanted to go to prison that's
right 65 year old Donald Matthew Santa
Croce handed a Wells Fargo bank teller a
note last week the note said quote
please pardon me for doing this but this
is a robbery please give me one dollar
thank you the teller gave Santa Croce a
one dollar bill and then asked him to
leave but he told the bank teller to
call police and then sat in the lobby
until they arrived he handed responding
officers the one dollar bill and asked
to be jailed in federal prison
unfortunately for Santa Croce he wasn't
sent to federal prison instead was
booked in the Salt Lake County Jail on a
robbery charged
Terry I don't know about this one what
do you think is going to go on here I
mean why would someone ask to be sent to
federal prison I don't get the advantage
there you know we have seen that federal
prison is better than State Prison I
don't know why anyone would want to
commit a crime and go to prison but I'm
thinking listen He is 65 years old and
he will get food he will get shelter and
that may have been part of what was
going on there which is a bad sad sad
you know reflection on society today and
it's happened before we know in 2011 in
North Carolina a very similar situation
occurred there was another bank robbery
for a dollar and the man wanted to go to
prison as well and you know it happened
in California and in all of these cases
it's a person who doesn't have a lot and
who is looking to get shelter and
medical care so it really does reflect
on society and I think it really is
something that needs to be addressed in
the entire system one thing I'll add is
you can't decide whether you go to
federal or state and so it's no federal
crime here there was no violation of a
federal statute there was no violation
of the Constitution so he went to County
Jail which is oftentimes nowhere near as
nice as if you can call it nice is
nowhere near safe and the food is better
so people if they have to go would
rather go to Federal Court it feels a
little bit like the Shawshank Redemption
I think the character was Brooks who
wanted you know to go back to prison and
look I think the details will surround
about why that might have been I want to
ask Brian a legal question here no gun
no threats we know robbery kind of you
need that kind of that level of threat
or intimidation or Force how is this a
robbery so yes and no you do you need a
level of threat I think when most people
when they hear robbery they think of the
typical bank robber that you see on TV
and they're coming and I was like Catch
Me If You Can copper is in the running
out guns are blazing but you actually
don't need that in Most states and
especially in this state as well so the
ones you're thinking about in terms of
robbery use of force or fear of of
immediate use of force so gun or a
shooting or just saying hey I got a gun
I want to rob you but there's also
another point of robbery as well and
that's wrongful appropriation it is
wrongful for you to go to a bank and
take money that is not yours you're
you're taking it from them even though
you're not using force or the threat of
that Force so I think that this is
robbery where I've seen it in New York
is the aggressive panhandler the
panhandler keeps saying hey give me a
dollar give me a dollar give me a dollar
give me a dollar they're not holding up
with a gun but that aggression and maybe
a little bit of fear is why you give
that dollar that can be considered a
form of robbery even though I argue it
all the time that it's not yeah and they
could say look he said it's a robbery
this is a complete stranger maybe we
felt a little uneasy so I can see how
they try to make out the case Terry
Bryan thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we're going to see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
foreign